I think what I'm pleased about in these
results where we grew the top-line four
and a half expanded margins and had very
strong cash flow is the consistency
across the world and and also across
categories and brands Scotch whisky was
up five percent and Johnnie Walker up
six percent
brands like Macallan 16 but the US
business is coming back we grew us
spirits 3.4 percent Europe was really
strong 5% growth in Europe and brands
like Bailey's and Captain Morgan doing
really well
Guinness is and strong health so this is
more consistent than we've done in in
quite a few years so what was really
striking things in results is it China
was up 25% it's early days but I really
sensed China is at the early stage of
the development of a very exciting
high-end Scotch whisky Renaissance and
brands like Johnnie Walker Blue Label
are single malts
we're opening whisky boutiques and towns
where people are really getting
interested in whisky and all the the
heritage and quality and stories behind
it so we've had a good good year and
scotch we're growing market share there
and I think if I look at the next 10
years I think Scotch can be very
exciting in China as well now what in
fact Britain's impending exit from the
EU you were very clear before the
referendum you wanted the UK to remain
in the EU now you've made it clear that
you don't see WTO tariffs as being
necessarily a problem in some parts of
the world what about economies like
Colombia and Peru and South Africa where
the EU has free trade deals with those
economies are you going to face higher
tariffs on some of your products well
we're working with the government
closely on this where we're taking
brexit in our stride and in those
markets where indeed Scotch whisky
benefits from some of the EU FTA
agreements like a Colombia or indeed a
Korea we're working with the government
to ensure that the UK doesn't
go backwards when we allowed the EU and
I'm fairly confident we would because I
would hope that those markets will not
want to be lies the UK because there's
two-way trade there but these are all
the areas in which Scotch whisky is such
a successful export industry from the UK
it's 25% of the food and drink business
it's four billion pounds supports 40,000
people in Scotland it's a growth
industry I mean I see a lot of
opportunity to keep Scotch growing fast
and both the UK and the Scottish
governments are very aligned and
ensuring that we get the support so I
would hope in in the case of those
countries we would get trading
arrangements as favorable as we have
today and the Scottish Government's
latest appeal as it tries to drive
through minimum pricing is about to come
to court again sensational results today
very very strong profits a lot of people
who look at the minimum pricing debate
in Scotland will probably say isn't it
slightly immoral to to be opposing
mineral pricing our approach is to
reduce alcohol Harman society we have a
huge commitment to it it's core to what
we do if you look at the trends in the
UK over the last 1012 years you've had
reduction in binge drinking harmful
drinking to the tune of 20 percent
taking place in Scotland in the last
decade alcohol-related deaths have
dropped by about 30 percent now there's
always more to do and our approach on
reducing alcohol harm is it needs to be
targeted we need to target populations
where the problem is you need solutions
that work and we're doing a lot of
programs around the world we measure
their effectiveness and so our approach
on this is there are better ways and we
want to work closely with government
with the medical community with
stakeholders to reduce alcohol harm and
it's something I think we can make a
real difference on